[Music]
there was something about that unique
combination of people that came together
how do you harness that energy that
desire of your own people to do
something good wherever you are I think
that's when the best stuff
happens today I'm joined by Ed kmall as
co-founder of Pixar and later as
president of Walt Disney Animation
Studios Ed played an absolutely key role
in shaping that company's unique culture
of colle collaboration which has gone on
to become the gold standard for Creative
workplaces worldwide if you've ever been
captivated by a Pixar film I'm sure you
have Wall-E is my
favorite wall well you got Ed to thank
for that he is a mastermind of
innovation he's a Pioneer in both
technology and storytelling and the
absolute OG when it comes to creative
leadership it was quite the honor to
engage him on the creative principles
the management principles that fueled
Pixar success we talk about the insights
that literally changed workplace
practices all across the world to better
foster creativity and continuous
learning and how embracing failure
creates this beautiful path to growth Ed
also shares incredible stories from his
fascinating life as well as from his
close relationship with both George
Lucas and Steve Jobs now 78 Ed is a
profound thinker and this conversation
is action-packed with invaluable lessons
on Innovation on leadership and also on
the magic and meaning of living a good
life you're in for a treat so off we go
this is me and Ed
[Music]
katal I'm extremely proud to introduce
you to our newest brand partner on check
out their lineup of super comfortable
sleek and durable pieces for for
yourself at
[Music]
on.com it is a real uh thrill to meet
you and it's an honor to have you here
today to you know share your experience
and and and your wisdom everything
that's in this book creativity Inc which
is just a wonderful mustre for anybody
whether whether you're a business person
or not because there's a lot of valuable
wisdom um for not just how to manage
people and get the best out of them and
operate uh you know a creative
innovative business but it's really a
primer for life and then reflecting on
your life um it's a it's a relatively
unlikely story on some level I mean I
know that as a young person you had this
idea that you wanted to be the best in
the world at something and I'd be
curious as to what prompted that in you
but you are brought up on a steady diet
of physics and engineering and these
aren't the curriculums that one would
think would contribute to you know a
leadership position or a position in the
creative arts I think maybe it would be
instructive to start a little bit at the
beginning and talk about how you got
into all of this from the start as
somebody who was immersed in science and
had certain Heroes and had a vision for
you know the life that you wanted to
live I I was very fortunate to have
grown up in the 50s in Salt Lake City it
was a safe environment a supportive
environment and uh I did have this
feeling I wanted to be the best in the
world of something I actually don't
remember where they came from to be
honest yeah I'm interested like what
were your parents like where did that
come from uh uh my father was one of uh
uh there were there were 14 children but
only nine of whom survived to adulthood
wow on a on a farm in Idaho so so they
were you know very poor um
he uh uh he was in the Marines in during
World War II he was uh
strict but he was a very nice man and he
was teaching high school as I was
growing up I was teaching math and then
later got his doctor's degree and became
a principal honestly it was a great
environment to grow up in when when I
left high school I'd originally wanted
to be an
animator um because my childhood Heroes
were Walt Disney and uh obviously
influenced by him and uh but also Albert
Einstein so like these are the I iconic
figures of the time and what is the
shared DNA between those two individuals
for you well the shared experience for
me was these were people that were
changing the
world and uh they did it by creating
something
new and I knew that Walt Disney had
basically created a company when he made
uh Snow White which is the first major
animated film it wasn't the first
animated film there a couple that were
done before
that but um that one was the one that
changed the way storytelling was done so
he was essentially figuring that out but
in terms of knowing about him and
reading about him and studying him I I
could say okay this was a person who
figured out how to storytelling but then
there was a series of
films that were impactful for me as a as
a child probably two most most impactful
films were Peter Pan and Pinocchio was
it the storytelling was it the Art of
Animation was it you trying to
deconstruct how they actually created
these movies what about it captured your
imagination this is what good
storytelling does for children and I
think it's very important to have
children have these uh their
imaginations uh developed and challenged
and pushed I that's what I experienced
from those
films and I also experienced the
childhood in which we played outside a
lot you know parents read to kids so um
there was some combination of all those
things which I thought were good for me
when I was growing up I like that going
forward it's like okay can I do
something like that so you end up at
University of Utah and this is where it
gets really interesting I think because
it was a very specific moment in time at
a very particular place in which a group
of IND individuals happen to congregate
that end up going in their own unique
ways to change the world and all kinds
of ways like it was the birthplace of so
much like you were involved in arpa like
this is the original version of the
internet and on The Cutting Edge of you
know what computers could possibly do in
animation yes but also in other
disciplines and you were surrounded by a
lot of kind of amazing young people at
that time and also had some pretty
significant mentorship so talk a little
bit about that magical period of time
that that really provided the foundation
for everything that followed when I was
there I did know the place that it was
special I didn't know how special it was
but I knew it was special uh it had been
founded by Dave Evans and Ivan
southernland uh Ivan sou had actually
been one of the leaders at uh arpa who
was funding these kind of programs
around the United
States um and Alan Kay was
there uh who also had a profound
influence on on computer
science um and Alan Kay was one of my
first teachers and he taught this
principle which actually seemed natural
to me but it was that things are going
to keep changing at a faster
rate and it was like this is what's
likely to
happen and uh and it actually stuck
because I was making decisions
throughout my life based upon the fact
that the rate of change is going to
increase so that was one major influence
the other one was that Ivan Southerland
was the essentially the first person to
really get computer Graphics going and
it was Harvard that he built the first
head-mounted display for virtual reality
and artificial reality but the key thing
that that Ivan had was that you can have
a big
Vision you don't know
exactly what where where it's going or
what it's going to get there but you can
take some steps to get there so
everything at that program was taking
step by step developments towards that
big bigger
vision and as you took those steps you
were also modifying where you thought
you could go so our job is graduate
students was to take the next step now
other thing I will notice this just an
observation of places that turn out a
significant number of impactful people
is there is no real
curriculum the people who are doing it
are are figuring it out as they go and
there's something which is like isn't
just educational working on problems
it's actually really educational and you
have to figure out what it is that you
should be learning and Dave and Ivan set
up the
program so that we were all helping each
other and sharing in the
ideas and we were the ones who were
solving the
problems so by the time I graduated four
years after
entering um I had made my own
contributions I had friends among these
people but I realized
that I loved it there so when you when
you were in school you you made your own
animated film of your hand right and by
some accounts that was the first or one
of the very first computer animated
films correct yes now there was another
student who a student who made a a movie
of his wife's face uhhuh we actually
showed them together okay so you two
together but basically if not the first
like one of the very first ever computer
generated yes films you created that you
had this ambition of creating a feature
computer animated
film Pixar is sort of organized around
that principle so a big part of the
Pixar success
equation is is this idea of of
developing Talent inhouse bringing in
these people with potential nurturing
them surrounding themselves with
surrounding them with really competent
people and then on top of that
establishing this culture of feedback
and um permissiveness in in which uh
ideas could be shared and uh and and and
done in a way in which it wasn't about
judgment or about you know the value or
the selfworth of the the individual but
really about the ideas themselves this
notion of people over ideas and the
question is how do you get people to
think that way and uh every time we made
a film every time we made made a mistake
we would do some self assessment is okay
what was working what wasn't working and
what was the
value and often realizing that our
assumptions that we made in the past
actually were the wrong
assumptions but because everybody was
thinking this
way then we could challenge ourselves
fairly early so an example of that would
be that we did recognize the value
Disney provided us for Toy Story So we
had was an outside force that had a
vested interest in our
success and they weren't sort of Lost in
what we were doing and that was very
valuable and that lasted through
the first few films was Tom schumach was
the
president and we respected him because
he was really very creative and he knew
what we were doing and when he said
something it was you know objective but
objective as a person who understood
making
films but we also realized that as our
films started to become successful and
he was going to move over to uh the
theatrical in New York for making their
Broadway
musicals that we were going to lose that
outside
force so uh Andrew Stanton brought this
up and uh uh which was that let's have a
Brain Trust to serve that role for the
other directors that were developing so
this is an
idea we put it into play and originally
had like six people in it now it turns
out this thing called The Brain Trust
actually did not serve the rool of an
outside the original intent of this did
not succeed for which it was intend in
the way it was
intended but we found that when he did
this that it was extremely good at
giving feedback to people and in helping
them so at this point we sort of dropped
the original thing for it the original
idea and said okay let's develop this
group as a great feedback mechanism now
we had a new question how do we have
this group work what are the rules tools
that make it work so then we're learning
from each
film um because what you see sometimes
is people do have EG that get in the way
or they don't want to embarrass somebody
or they don't want to embarrass
themselves like so these are not real
human emotions that are in the way and
and then we recognize also that if
you're doing something new and you're
presenting it to people who are very
good at what they're doing you can feel
a little
nervous about it or
vulnerable and so you have to recognize
okay um if they're vulnerable then how
do we actually understand that and
appreciate it and not threaten that we
also learned if a person with a powerful
Voice or which act actually power with
actual power started the discussion
started to talk that distorted the
room because then people would respond
to what the powerful person say mhm and
so what it meant was that the person
with power needed to shut up for the
first 15 minutes and then enter the
discussion because if they enter that's
an entirely different thing than
studying the tone I asked Steve Jobs to
never come to one of the meetings uhuh
of course he's dying It's Curious like
what's like he it's he wants to be there
right the minute he walks in everybody's
going to you know the sphincter tighten
and everybody wants to make a good
impression on him it changes the dynamic
completely and I would suspect even
yourself at some point walking into
these meetings tilts the scales in a
certain way well actually I don't
because I'm I have a very different
personality and uh I don't impose myself
in the room and while it's fun to give a
note I've only made one note the in all
these years that I was there that had an
influence on the film but that says more
about your unique kind of energy and
sense of ability around these sorts of
things because for the most part in any
other organization anytime a a boss or a
leadership Authority enters one of these
rooms it's going to have that kind of
negative impact it screws things up yeah
so the boss has to realize their impact
on the room and sometimes you just don't
want to set the tone now the interesting
thing was with with Steve is that it
wouldn't matter uh when he spoke even if
he shut up for 10 minutes minutes um
when he did uh talk he's so powerful it
would be overwhelming and he understood
that so he didn't come to the
meetings uh however because at this
point we're now a public company the
films were shown to the board of
directors and the board of directors is
when he would give some notes and what
Steve would do the morning of any board
of directors meeting meeting because we
were shown the current film and then
we'd have a a session where the board of
directors would talk with the director
and the and the producer just to give
some feedback in the morning Steve would
call me and he would say these are very
short discussions he said Ed how's it
going on the film and I would say it's
going well great end of discussion or we
have a problem
okay but I wouldn't tell him what to do
because I never told Steve how to think
so if he knew there was a problem he
would then come and he would uh start uh
you know when he got to this part of the
discussion he'd start off by saying to
the director you can ignore everything
I'm going to say because I'm not a
director and you guys know things that I
don't know so these just my my comments
from seeing it he would then give some I
would say very insightful notes about
the film and he would
see now the interesting thing to me was
that the directors would say that Steve
had an insight about the films that
nobody else had and they heard things
from him they'd never heard
before except that I'm in all of these
meetings I've heard everybody give all
their notes there was never ever
anything that Steve said about a film
that had not been said by somebody else
before one of their colleagues right so
what it meant was that people that work
together often also learn how to ignore
each other that's a problem that's why
you need an outside force MH but Steve
understood it and so for many years he
was the outside force and he recognized
by this time his impact on people so
sometimes because he was I would say
became very empathetic after this 91 to
95 period if he s if he thought he had
too large of an impact he would take
them for a walk to calm them
down yeah that's a great level of
self-awareness around your own power
yeah I just yeah I me he knew it yeah
it's interesting there's a certain kind
of interesting you know perhaps somewhat
ironic uh kind of veneer to this in that
your original motivation into rethinking
management and Leadership and and on
some level the impetus of the book was
trying to figure out why great companies
when they reach a certain level of scale
suddenly no longer are great right for
me it's a it's a fascinating thing
because I see it just happened in
company after company is what is
actually going on what are people
thinking the one of the difficulties
that companies have is that because of
underlying changes that take place and
this in particular it's true with
computer related companies but now it's
happening everywhere is there are
fundamental changes that are taking
place uh not only in the technology but
in its applications and now because of
the use of uh more computers and and and
cell phones and the whole we system of
of transfering information but also
societal changes and environmental
changes uh a lot of things are happening
pretty rapidly and people have
difficulty conceive conceiving of what
it means to change their business plan
let alone other things they need to do
in their lives but it's very hard for
them to conceive of it and Steve was
unusual in that his focus on is was on
what is the right thing to do when uh he
they were working on the uh the
iPhone but when it was secret yeah so he
went up to the secret lab to see it and
what he said was we're reaching the
point where there isn't really any you
know a lot more growth in the laptop
computers or including the uh the
portable computers so we're going to
need to have a different business model
going forward now that in
itself is very unusual right so that's
one thing that I found interesting just
okay that sort of sets them apart from
other
people and the second one and this is
one that's uh difficult for people to
see because they've got a pretty deep
understanding of the Arc of Steve's life
there's a reason for that
misunderstanding and that was he started
off he had behaviors he had those those
behaviors when I first knew him and he
first acquired Pixar it was not easy to
work with when he was that way but he
changed over time because his story is
more like the hero's journey and know he
he's got his own kingdom which is Apple
he's cast out for some
reason and in this case it's a fairly
public humiliation
and uh uh so he started next he bought
Pixar and and frankly neither company
was working out very well so and in the
case of next uh he made a brilliant
software
choice and Brilliant software decisions
uh some questionable Hardware design
decisions and some poor business
decisions but he's really smart he could
recognize them for what they were and he
learned from them and I would say that
in from the years around 91 to 95 there
was a dramatic change in Steve's life
and after he went through that
change the people who were with him
stayed with him for the rest of his life
and what was the nature of that change
was it a result of you know kind of the
the excavation of the soul that came
with getting cast out in in this hero's
journey or what did he do specifically
that you're aware of that created a
different growth trajectory for him for
him the underlying thing Steve did
understand was that you have to find out
what the truth is an adapt to it if
something wasn't right he would
switch uh so I could see that happening
so as as he was going through these
things at both companies he was changing
things
now what started in
991 is 91 when was when he got married
MH uh he had a son
Reed um Pixar entered into a
relationship with Disney the contract to
make Toy Story and U the whole industry
went through this massive transformation
from 91 to
95 which had big implications bigger
than most people are aware of and 95
Pixar went public so Pixar going public
was the first actual real business
success for Steve since he left Apple it
was a real stroke of Genius also and and
to your point about his uncanny ability
to cast his gaze into the future and
understand how things would would play
out the decision to IPO Pixar on the
cusp of releasing its very first movie
seems rather
uh and and must have struck all of you
as as as somewhat strange thinking why
would we do this now we have one movie
Let's establish ourselves let's make a
couple movies before we do that but
explain why Steve made that decision and
how that played out because I think it's
a great test case or a very kind of
instructive lens into the way that this
guy thought and what made him unique and
different and special the it we did
think that this was pushing too fast all
of us thought that this is like okay
this is nuts to go public right after
the movie came out I mean you had this
deal with Disney you had Toy Story which
was completed and about to be released
but nobody knew how that was going to do
right like the like paint a little bit
of a picture of of the nature of Pixar
at that time well because basically we
were failing as a company and he'd put
like $50 million into it which was a
substantial portion of his net worth and
you almost sold the GM at some point
right like you were going to be a 3D
modeling company well this is before
then this is when we were spinning out
of Lucas film so uh uh General Motors
and Phillips uh medical were going to
buy
us and it fell apart at the last minute
because of an internal conflict within
General Motors between the Eds
people and the and the car making people
so it's a it's an obscure thing but we
are caught up in that and so it all fell
apart so we kept going through this
difficult process of getting somebody to
buy us and we finally got General Motors
and EDS to
agree and then after they agreed within
a week of signing they get into this
argument and it all fell apart then I
ran into Steve and Steve said how's it
going and I said no actually it's not
going well at
all but he had formed next computer yeah
in the in the meantime so now he had his
computer company now he was willing to
buy us on our terms which was that we
wanted to do computer graphics and make
computer
animation and he saw the
value of graphics for the future when
George hired
me um in uh this is
1979 he was the first person in the film
industry with credibility willing to put
money into this so basically he was the
only person in this industry that had
had any value there was still nobody in
the film industry that wanted to or
believed in in technology with one other
exception and that was Roy Disney jrh
Walt's
nephew and he understood something that
that was not part of of of Disney at
that time or any other company and that
was well
believed that
technology uh brought some energy into
the artistic process that was an unusual
thing and when he died that Spirit uh
didn't survive in the company it was at
Roy's insistence that Disney enter into
a contract with us to write software for
coloring
cells and their analysis of it was that
it didn't make any sense to do that but
Roy said this isn't about the
money it was about bringing in the
energy and very unusual thought process
and an investment in in the future
potentiality and possibilities that that
that that might reap once the technology
you know continued to advance and mature
so we entered into the contract uh Roy
was an advocate um we
the whole thing again was another
educational process but we worked very
hard to make sure that we did not let
Disney down from Steve's point of view
is like okay this is our big
opportunity so we entered into a
contract uh none of us had made an a
computer animated film none of us had
made an animated film or a film of any
kind so we were all beginners we had to
figure everything out in the process
but as we got near the end of it Steve
realized this is going to change the
industry and our deal actually isn't a
very good
deal so we start getting much from it
and also Michael Eisen will realize that
when the three pictures are up that we
delivered the three for the
contract that he will have then just
created his worst nightmare right the
idea being Toy Story is going to come
out it's going to be a huge hit Steve
could see this there was a lot of
excitement around that and you would be
stuck in this three picture deal with
unfavorable terms and Steve's Brilliance
was let's figure out a way to
renegotiate this deal and the best way
to do that is to IPO and stockpile a
bunch of cash so that when Michael
Eisner inevitably calls and says I want
to renegotiate this deal to tie you up
you then have leverage by Dent of all
this money to go back to him and push
for different terms basically an output
deal right where you would share you're
using Disney as a distribution arm uh in
a partnership in which the revenue share
was going to be on parody like 5050 as
opposed to the typical deal where you're
getting a small slice of you know Disney
you know gigantic take on a project yes
and the interesting thing about this was
that once day was at next he had some
he' made some deals which on the surface
looked great for him but in the end they
were bad deals he' made some essential
essentially he'd made some bad business
decisions in the past but he was smart
and he learned from them so he
approached this one as saying we need
need to be 50/50 Partners I'm not trying
to rake them over the co Kohls I don't
want us to get raked over it's like we
need to approach this as partners so for
me this is the maturation that's coming
out of the lessons he'd learned from the
past so he approached this of saying
we're we want to be partners with each
other and think of it this way which
meant that we have to have the money to
to be able to say yes we're both in
investing equally in this it's it's an
unbelievable story of of foresight Steve
would was a person who wasn't rigorous
about whatever the business plan was but
was always looking forward and
anticipating where the business should
go which requires not just a level of of
maturity and perhaps some some you know
level of Genius as well but the ability
to hold Loosely and remain really
striding about your values and your
conviction about moving the company in
the direction of the future so so that
you don't get out innovated and you
don't end up like sun Microsystems or
silicon Graphics or or
Kodak if Steve saw in the directors of
our films what he believ was necessary
for anybody that was going to do
something new and that was you commit to
something with
passion and when you're you're wrong you
change and that that's hard for people
to hold on to their head because you
think if I'm committed that I'm
committed I'm not going to listen to
things that's going to change my course
because I'm committed to the course but
if I'm not committed then I change
course too easily so what does it mean
to to both be committed and at the same
time say oh um I've just realized I'm
wrong we're going to change that's very
hard and I'd say the best leaders the
best filmmakers that's what they do
we're going to go down this path okay
it's not working we're going to change
yeah so how do you be how do you uh do
both at the same time and it is
possible um but that's when the you I
think that's when the best stuff happens
yeah well the way that it's possible is
through these many kind of systems and
philosophies that you end up
implementing at Pixar that creates this
unbelievable run of extraordinary movies
over the tenure of of your leadership
there every athlete I know is going to
tell you that having the right gear is
key to Performance if what you're
wearing is poorly crafted it's just
going to put distance between you and
those goals you've set you owe it to
yourself to invest in the best and the
best is on I'm obsessed with the cloud
Ultra great on the trails and I just got
the new NextGen Cloud Stratus 3 for the
road I'm Ling those but an also has this
incredible line of lightweight high
performance apparel that it's just
beyond anything I've previously dawned
it's like this second to none Second
Skin I love to rock the sweat wicking
Ultra te and the ultra shorts which have
this pocket right at the base of the
spine that perfectly anchors your phone
no jiggle I'm just so proud to partner
with an and I love their vision for the
future where their gear is fossil free
and engineered for circularity so check
out their amazing lineup of super
comfortable sleek and durable pieces for
yourself at
on.com on this idea of the Brain Trust
though the overarching idea here is how
do we get the most compelling Innovative
creative work out of this group of
people and what is the environment that
we need to cultivate in order to
facilitate that the Brain Trust is just
one of many things that I think you
implemented during your your tenure at
at at Pixar um but before we move on to
the others like what so what became the
rules of this Brain Trust like how was
it organized and deployed to its maximum
effect well there are a a few basic
principles that uh that went into
running it one of them is that it really
needed to be a room of of
filmmakers who knew about film so it
wasn't for gawkers or others who want to
see because a lot of people wanted to
see what was going on in the room but
that's not what it was
for um so it was peer talking to Pier
the other one was that uh which is
important is that that room and the
people in the room could not override
the director of that the creative team
and and that was very important and we
also didn't do anything significant like
if we knew there was a serious problem
we didn't actually make any moves before
or within two weeks roughly after the
Brain Trust meeting because we didn't
want the meeting overloaded like if if
this doesn't go right you know it's an
utter disaster we're just trying to make
it so that we can focus on the room and
not be too worried about other
things the other rule is that as you
just have to be honest with each other
and uh but I would say because people
have done this for years and they know
each other that we've actually reached
they have a good state of being honest
with each
other and but part of that a learn
behavior and as we bring in new people
they would observe it and they'd realize
oh it's okay to say something which
doesn't work and every once in a a while
uh Magic would
happened and by magic I mean that uh
Eagles left the room that is when I say
Eagles left the room is people could say
something they weren't attached to their
ideas if they worked great if they
didn't work that's okay too I'm not
attached to it and for me that's the the
ideal state to be in it's probably like
flow you've heard in light a number of
areas but it's like when a room gets
into that state then it's pretty amazing
to watch yeah I would imagine I think
that creativity isn't something that you
can just summon it's not uh you know a
product of a board meeting there's a
there's a ethereal quality to it right
and creating an environment that's
conducive to the Sparks and the flow and
getting the best and brightest Minds to
collide with each other to have
something emerge that's greater than the
sum of its parts is a real art
yes and and that's the job yeah is to
get that done right I'm sure people ask
you this all the time they come to you
maybe they run a small business or a
large organization or they're a manager
of a department at a company and they
say Ed how do I get the best out of my
people I just everyone's operating
suboptimally I don't know how to
motivate my people the work that's
coming out of my department just is
stale it's not Crea creative what is the
advice that you give to that person
who's looking to instill that creative
flare and a permissive environment in
which new ideas and uh and you know the
opportunity to fail and fail fast uh can
be part of the you know the environment
to make something new and better and
different well there there are there are
two things that sort of popped my mind
on that one of them is I talked about
failure in the book and the meaning of
it then I realized actually we don't use
the term failure very much inside of
Pixar um now we do if we actually have
something fails we say that it fails
we're not trying to avoid it but the
word's too
loaded um because uh you know starting a
school if you
fail in a class then that's a bad thing
because it means you weren't smart
enough or you didn't work hard
enough um but also when you get out and
bridges fail uh relationships
fail um companies fail and in business
and
politics failure is a bludgeon with
which you beat opponents so there's a
real imp palpable Aura of danger around
failure while we also would say that
we've learned a lot from our failures
because we have we all recognize that is
that meaning of failure is actually sort
of overridden by the danger part of
failure and so okay I just it's just
true it doesn't matter what we say about
it we don't have the luxury of calling a
failure educational until after it
happens not before it happens if we
recognize that then say well okay there
are a lot of times when we should be
using a somewhat different terminology
which is that we're trying to make make
something work let's try this though
that didn't work let's try this we don't
need to overload it so I try to be very
careful about the words and how they're
used it's a terrible word there should
be a different neutral word that
encourages people to extend themselves
irrespective of whether it works out or
not without you know fear of losing
their job or you know the kind of
internal shame or guilt system that that
happens when you know you quote unquote
fail it's so loaded and I think it you
know it it it paralyzes people yeah so
if say okay why do people get paralyzed
so our terminology does it sometimes uh
it's one of the reasons I try to use in
general not always but I try to use
cander instead of honesty because
honesty is sort of like the opposite
where uh you say well of course I'm
unhonest person when when actually that
isn't the right word because the
opposite of honest is dishonest
but there are times when you may not be
candid for a variety of reasons the
opposite of candid is not candid it's
not as loaded so these words have these
subtle effects on
people uh and failure is one that has a
a an effect on how people think it's
like I think it should be used for
things which are uh where you really do
have a a major
problem U and the other one is people
get stuck for different
reasons so in the case of of making
films if you assign somebody uh like you
say this person can be a
director then we came up with something
which was very effective which
was and this just all this was
recognizing that when people are trying
to solve a problem they get stuck we all
do this you're trying to work on
something Bang Your Head on the
wall and I remember this you know from
like just doing homework work or Mak in
school right yeah sometimes you're
trying to do it you got to do it you got
to
schedule my I'm sorry my brain is fried
I'm stuck so the the issue for us was
how do we keep people from getting stuck
so the thing we tried which is uh was
quite effective was to have people pitch
three ideas for movies now there are a
couple of people who don't work that way
they've got the idea and they're going
to make it that's fine we're just
we're just trying to help people uh keep
from getting stuck and when we ask
somebody to come up with the uh the
ideas for a film um and we say three
then what that lets him do is bounce
back and forth between them and they do
this over a period of a year because if
we're going to do a film we've got a
director uh typically a writer and a and
a couple of creative people are
supporting them like it's really tiny
team and this rather amazing phenomenon
happens and that is every time somebody
produces or or pitches the film they
start off by saying I love all three
ideas equally MH and now they they don't
yeah that's a lack of
Candor and it say but it's also you say
okay that's what it means to be
vulnerable right it's what if I'm wrong
what if they see something I don't see
so you're essentially you're signaling
the other people it's like you won't
hurt my feelings if you pick one of the
other things so like that's a self
protection
mechanism but actually what we want to
know is which is the one that they want
to do and we know completely that that
if they if we pick one of them it's
going to change dramatically in any case
so my favorite story was with uh Leonor
on on uh Coco a story an idea would be
presented and there's artwork they'd
picked up or drawn or or whatever to
convey the idea very rough we all know
that it's not a final movie idea it's a
pitch for a start of an idea discuss it
20 25 minutes is what we' take on this
and then we'd switch to the other
story and then with Leonor after we did
this we went into the other room open up
the door the table the back wall both
walls the ceilings are covered with
Mexican artwork mhm so without a word
being said everybody knows which film
we're going to
make now the thing about this
is the film that was made in the end was
actually radically different than what
was pitched at that point like but we
didn't care what we knew is he wanted to
make a movie and in that front in fact
originally he wanted to be a
musical and you know but a musical isn't
in his DNA so the very first song he had
which was remember me then became a sort
of a Core theme that's built into the
movie sort of the nature of the change
that happens but it's an example of we
put something in place to help someone
actually solve the problems because they
could always switch MH and then come
back to when they felt like they had
but the really important thing there was
the excitement that this person had for
that concept like that seemed to be one
of the more kind of you know important
aspects of all the pitches like this
guy's on to something super motivated he
clearly you know wants to do this and
that's something that we as a company
that supports people over ideas can get
behind and Marshal art resources to to
support and over time it will become
something very different but let's pay
attention to what he's saying to us now
which is less about the pitch and more
about the energy that he's going to
bring to what might be you know two
years of of working on something is that
is
that energy is
contagious and then and then he knows
that the people around him are going to
bring something and in this case because
it's about the a Mexican
holiday then they went they visited the
U uh southern Mexico and the villages to
what's it really like uh and they went
several times and they had advisors
because they didn't want to operate off
of their biases other words we all know
something about various things just like
we know something about cooking and so
forth but in the case of rouille you
actually need to go into a high-end
restaurant to see what it's really like
and with each one of those cases as an
audience we don't really
know and and and the directors when they
start they don't really know what it's
like in these places but if you get it
right if you actually bring something
from the culture or from the place or
what you're doing and you put it in the
film The Audience senses that is correct
yeah even if they don't know it's true
there's a sense they they they can feel
that energy right and that attention to
detail yes and and I think that's what
it is with it's like actually with with
any company or with any product that's
out there it's like do people care about
it are they paying attention to the
detail and are they just slapping it out
you want people to care wherever
whatever field they're in and so how do
you do that how do you get the people
working within your
organization to Care on the level that's
required for that to get transmitted
into the product whatever it is and give
the consumer or the customer that
feeling well I for me the big step is is
that when you see that there's a problem
you have to ask
why and and you it isn't one of those
things that you can force on them you
say you need to do this you need to fix
it this way which is a natural thing for
people to do I don't think it's the
right thing to do though it's like okay
this isn't going the way I would hope it
it's going why isn't it going this way
what's getting in their way and what can
I do to solve the thing that's getting
in their way because they may not see it
and if they don't see it and I'm not
paying attention then we all miss it and
then it still it sits there and it
festers and it affects people but we can
ask and and figure out what act happened
why did it happen and what what can we
do about it Pixar is in the business of
taking creative ideas and putting them
into a story crafting a story and
sharing that story with the World by its
very definition it is a creative
business but is there not an argument
that every business is a creative
business like how do you define
creativity and what is the role that
creativity plays in in an organization
or a business or an industry that people
don't typically think of as being
creative with quot marks around it well
I it's clear that people would consider
the Arts and film and writing forth to
be creative so that's clear I think most
people would say it's that if you're
designing products that's creative or if
you're in the Sciences or certain things
that that's creative but they kind of
stop around there and I personally I
believe solving problems is creative so
if you got problems in your family or in
your neighborhood and you're able to
work them out with people that's a
creative act and for me solving problems
is a creative act and I think that that
creating an
organization that is better for people
and that brings the best out of them is
a creative act
also and I it's because I look at a lot
of what I've done it's like trying to
solve the problems mhm and so so oh
that's you know that's actually the the
bigger contribution I've I've had
because the original thing that I did
like yeah those can happen anyway but
but trying to create a
culture well that applies everywhere and
because people are so
incomprehensible the problem of trying
to create a culture that motivates
people and creates a sustainable output
of innovation and creative ideas that
trickle into the products that it makes
or whatever it is that it does um is a
creative acting and of itself like I
think that creativity is at the core and
is of the essence of of anybody who's
trying to do anything either
individually or as a collective as a
group call it a corporation a school
whatever it is and I think appreciating
the power of uh of the creative impulse
and and
understanding um how to how to initiate
that and cultivate that and and respect
that in the people that you're working
with and and in yourself really feels to
me like super important if not the most
important thing that you're trying to
kind of instill in the people around you
who have a collective goal that you're
all kind of working towards is that
overstating it to you but like that's
really the the kind of heart and soul of
what your book is about and what you
were trying to do at Pixar it is
it's it's how those people do it
together you know what's our
responsibility in enabling it making it
safe how do we send messages to people
uh you know in in a a room where things
are sort of rush is is is it safe for
the least powerful person in the room to
talk
talk uh like is like a message in fact
there's one example that took place it's
one I I loved it at Pixar because
usually we've got these uh really tight
schedules and you you get a group of
people who are working on it and they're
very good at what they do but they never
have enough time so when they have their
meetings there's a lot they're under a
lot of pressure so we had one of the
leaders uh and one of these groups where
they're just you know you know really
smart and high-powered people but this
leader said he wanted to make sure that
every person in the room could talk but
in the room they're production
assistants so these are people that are
hired because of high potential but
actually they don't have any experience
and they don't know anything about the
particular problem in any
case so he told them he told the the
people this is the way he wanted to work
and the other people who were objected
only on the ground so they didn't have
enough time they didn't have anything
against the person I thought they the
others were ni they were good people
they had high potential all those things
they could agree on is we literally
don't have the time so he said no this
is the way we're going to work now the
interesting thing was by the end of the
film everybody thought it was the right
thing to do because when he did
that uh they knew they were sending a
message to the person who was the
production assistant they were valued
but for the people who were supposed to
be in the discussion it was a message to
them that we value everybody and they
ended up feeling a lot better about it
also oh that's interesting it's one of
those things where he was trying to do
one thing but he actually got two
because it's basically giving a signal
about a value there's a quote uh that's
super interesting to me uh in which he
said if you don't try to uncover what is
unseen and understand its nature you
will be ill prepared to
lead and your story reminds me of this
quote but I thought I'd give you an
opportunity to explain what you mean by
that I do feel like there are so many
things that we can't see in the world or
we we don't know what's going to
happen uh it's just the nature reality
and we we tend to hold on to things that
we can see or grab on to the experiences
that we've got because they're solid
they may be good experiences but they
think that's you know if we just repeat
that I don't know what the right
terminology for it is I mean I've used
the term the unknown MH I don't the
thing was I haven't found a word that
works well because it's unknown it's you
know you can't see what it is it's
obscure it's for some people
conceptually it's like a you know a 2X
two chart you know it's like you know
you fall into one of these categories
the problem is it doesn't give any
notion of the size of each of them so
the stuff that we know we know like
that's one piece but we also acknowledge
I think clearly that there are
Physicians or physicists or experts in
these field and the total amount of
stuff that we don't know we kind of have
a sense like so that's a bigger thing we
can kind of get our head around it but
the stuff that we don't know that we
don't know
it's like that's gigantic it's huge so
how do you actually operate in a world
in which there's so many possibilities
of things and um in this case you're
actually working off of the way you
think about change your opportunity or
your value system you don't know what's
going to happen you know positive or
negative coming in your life I've just
accept that okay I don't know a lot
that's why I can't be right a lot and if
I can accept the fact that I really
don't know then I think it opens us up
to say oh I really do need help for
anybody at any level so if they come and
say there's a problem then I damn well
better listen because they are seeing
things that I can't see and it would be
actually uh very foolish of me to assume
that I know more than I do and and you
know in a lot of companies there's this
notion of there's a prep meeting before
the meeting because if the
leader in with in a lot of of places if
the if the manager or the leader gets
surprised in a meeting they're not happy
they got surprised basically it's
disrespectful it's the way it's treated
what's the purpose of the meeting if you
have to know ahead of time what it is
right well there's a you know people are
complicated and there's politics and
there's ego I mean essentially what I'm
getting from what you're sharing is is a
sense of humility and a almost
beginner's mind of of curiosity to lead
not from a place of I know all the
answers and I'm going to tell you what
to do but an appreciation that you don't
have all the answers and to uh you know
kind of come to a meeting with a with a
spirit of tell me more about what I
don't know that then percolates down and
gives everyone else permission beneath
that leader to have that same kind of
vibe about
themselves yes and there are times when
I've made serious
mistakes and people have come to me
afterwards to tell me that I made a
serious
mistake and I'm grateful they felt like
they could do
it and for me that's one of the most
important things is like if I make a
mistake somebody tells me I screwed
up um that they they could come without
fear doing that and it's like for me
that's like I feel good about that makes
me actually feel better even though I
feel bad about the mistake probably a
lot of leaders or bosses out there who
will tell their you know the people
beneath them like I want you to tell me
the truth I want you to come to me if
I'm getting it wrong but something about
their energy or some other aspect of how
they're leading uh creat a situation in
which that underlaying still doesn't
feel comfortable doing that yeah what
what are the consequences to them if
they say something that you don't like
right the leader says they want that but
do they really want that usually when
you have something like that something
happened which you don't
want um and it's just it's a nature of
things like oh you know that's a bad
thing but okay what does it mean to the
person who told you this mhm or
something you did personally MH um or
even something you disagree with often
uh people have disagreements about
things and uh and they're valid
disagreements but in somewhere you have
to make a choice it's not like um
everything is done by committee it's not
and and the person who's on the losing
end of that argument has to still feel
respected yes they need to feel like
they were listened to in fact I I for me
it's clear that it was more it's more
important for people to feel they're
listen to than it is for them to believe
they were correct or they the on some
argument or whatever is they need the
respect of being listened
[Music]
to when I think about all of these
principles that you instilled at Pixar
and and the way it's laid out in the
book which on some level on a surface
level I think you know reads like a
management book like this is how to run
a creative business whether it's the
Brain Trust or reframing failure or the
the rigorous testing that Pixar would do
and this understanding that every
project at the beginning was terrible
and it was only made better through you
know this process of of of you know
bringing that Brain Trust to all the big
creative decisions to make it better is
it too bold to suggest that these ideas
that you're proposing to get the best
out of people fall in to promote a
culture of
creativity has a um broader universality
Beyond business and in
applicability uh as to how to kind of
comport yourself in the world as to how
to live it's almost like a primer for
how you can interact with people and
engage with people and get together with
people to create things these are in
many ways not not necessarily just
principles for business but they are
principles for life I think the
principles of treating people well and
learning from them and growing and
helping them um you know they're I I
think they're unified mhm uh it's it's
always messy it's always hard and it
keeps changing and you don't actually re
reach the point where everything is
static and it's going to stay that way
forever uh so it it is a a statement of
life I do think like I've seen this get
lost in their goals to be in charge or
to make a lot of
money those things do happen they get in
the
way but I I don't think it's the way we
should be you know living as as people
as humans with each other is to let
those other aspirations get in the way
of how we treat people yeah I mean I'm
just thinking we can tease out any one
of these ideas or principles like take
the Brain Trust like everybody should
have their version of a Brain Trust in
their life we think about friends who
give us feedback or seeing a therapist
or finding a mentor but what you're
suggesting is a committee of trusted
people who contribute to the betterment
of a project or in the case of my
example the individual like everybody
should sort of go out into their
community and find people who can give
them that kind of trusted feedback and
create a structure around that as a a
vehicle for you know improving your
decisions and you know basically living
your life at a higher level of quality
but it doesn't seem like we think that
way it should be a a continual searching
process for
us and you know because for some people
I think they looking for or what is the
right thing to do you give me the answer
like and maybe they'll call one guy or
and that guy will say do this or don't
do that or maybe they'll just decide
themselves without any kind of feedback
or they'll call their
therapist yes how do we what if there
were 12 people that were weighing in on
that each with their own unique set of
Life Experiences who you know you could
weigh their input and then you know make
a decision based on that I mean I have
this in my life I have different groups
that I go to for various reasons that
really have been invaluable in in my
life and I just I want everyone to have
their version of that and it's obviously
something that we're trying to instill
in our you know in our office here with
our little Media company as students of
of you know what you Advocate and we've
been you know with great effect been
able to kind of put that into into
practice and I just think there's so
much value in doing that not just as
professionals but as individuals for the
quality of one's life yeah so then the
the the the interesting part is okay how
do you then think about it to to get
there like it becomes part of the search
so it's it isn't just having the group
that does that but it's okay if it's not
working how do I get it to work what's
what's not working working why doesn't
it
work and uh to me it's part of the the
discovery the continual Discovery
because it's not stable whatever it's
not stable but there still there's
there's that underlying
value that we have and if if we build on
that value which is is really a trust in
people MH assume that everybody is
well-meaning
is assume they've got it they might do
something to lose it but they don't have
to earn it yeah how can you be open how
can you hold your ideas Loosely how can
you be a champion for your colleagues
and the best idea how can you be a
better more active listener and also how
can you ask better questions like if you
want better Solutions you have to learn
how to ask better questions and I know
this is something you've thought thought
about and have written about how does
one figure out how to ask better
questions that's a good question how do
you figure this out and for me it was
always you pay
attention and if it's not working then
you say why is it not working for me
that's the question like why isn't
something going the way I want so if you
you essentially start with a question
you don't want you don't you don't want
to start with an answer because if you
start with the answer then you've
already figured it out well that's not
that's not a start that's an ending
point uh and it's one of the reasons why
I have I have some problem with mission
statements I mean I recognize in some
cases the mission statement actually
helps people get some
alignment um so it's not that I'm black
and white about it but the problem with
a lot of mission statements is that it
actually is starting with an
answer and uh that doesn't generate new
discussion so when never had anything
like our goal is to make the best films
or anything like that our mission
statement is to make the best films I'd
rather be um in a position where people
say well what are we doing here what is
our goal what are we trying to do
because you know what every time they
ask that question then they're thinking
about
it so and it's fluid it's fluid it
should always be fluid because the world
is fluid the world's fluid then we
should be able to respond
fluidly and one of the reasons I added
to the book was some people thought that
somehow after doing all this we had sort
of reached the point where we had
solved the problem of how we run a
creative
environment one said that isn't actually
what I
meant what I meant was we have a way of
thinking about it so we can continue to
adapt and and change and uh and ask
questions and figure things things out
because the the problems keep changing
mhm is that one of the reasons why you
decided to update the book yes there
there were things I had learned in the
intervening years because that was eight
eight nine years ago yeah that I wrote
it well there were there events took
place after
that uh and the other one was like
rethinking certain things I felt I need
to be a little clear about the Brain
Trust and its development rather than
like there's just a Brain Trust it's
like this is something that was a
special P
purpose adaptation to the way we were
doing things and if you're in a
different environment or in any company
it's like okay how do you think about
adapting it or building something for
yourself what's your mechanism for
getting really good uh feedback but also
good camarad with people for helping
each other but that's really the point
of it so so that was one of the things
um the other one was the realization
that um the the failure thing was
actually I don't think I fully was T was
was explaining well the notion that
there's a human
psychology coming behind failure which
is actually getting in the
way I know what's meant by it people say
like you learn from it so just do it and
get get it over
with and we'll we've said the same thing
too but it's not actually what we're
doing what we're trying to do is make it
possible for us to uh learn things try
things quickly and then if they don't
work we move on to something else so
trying to explain this concept of
holding on to
something and having a core of what
you're holding on to but at the same
time you change what you do each
person's different in the way they do
that I mean the way Steve does that was
very different the way I did it and I
never ever thought that I wanted to be
like him and he didn't want to be like
me either like why would you do that I'm
I'm not him you've said that you want
people to fail the elevator pitch
test what does that mean no what I what
I really said was is a a certain
percentage of what we're doing should
fail elevator test not everything does
it's like I'm not trying to make another
rule it's that if you have a certain
percentage of films that fail the
elevator test then this is something
about your ability to take risk and do
something that's risky so the concept of
the elevator pitch is that you have an
idea and you want to pitch the idea to
somebody who's got the authority to make
it happen you an executive or or whoever
it is and you can convey the idea so
succinctly and and clearly that in a
short period of time hence the elevator
test in a short period of time you can
do something which gets their interest
so that they would want to do it now the
problem with it is that the way to
always pass that elevator test is to do
something that's
derivative right because if you can
explain it quickly you're essentially
using examples of things that they get
they pretty much understand
and so if all you do that is you end up
actually becoming a fairly derivative
company now that being said Sometimes
you have a great idea and when you hear
it it's like oh yes we want to do that
so there are examples of that P doctor
you know saying I want to do this uh
although he would typically do the three
pitch test too but but in the case of uh
one film we had where he said c starting
over I I've got an idea that takes place
inside the head of a little girl and
deals with her emotions and we all
thought oh that's a great idea so boom
we're done right uh and but actually
playing like to actually explain what
that movie is about is there's no way
you're going to be able to do that noide
so but the the notion was okay what
pequs your interest that that's worth
doing so some things you actually you
get it okay let's go and try that it's
still nothing more than just like this
really rough idea and go through just as
long as any other film and just working
out even what that
means um that's all we had was you know
inside they head a little girl and then
there are some films like uh up and
Ratatouille where okay you say a movie I
want to make a movie about a rat that
cooks well you know you can't explain
why that's a good idea one minute you
can't explain why it's a good idea in a
week you can't explain why it's a good
idea a good idea in 3
months right it actually sounds like a
bad idea
right well it's all about the
execution yes and and the thing is when
you do something that's really hard and
some of these ideas are really hard
ideas that once you've said I'm going to
solve it you have to become more
creative you have to do something which
is unexpected to make it
work Ratatouille was probably one of the
more extreme ones but uh up was okay I
you know what does what does that even
mean you know it's it's sort of an odd
idea I tell a story about this old this
man that um is with his uh starting off
with his girlfriend and then they get
married married and then they they learn
they can have children and so they want
to go on a trip around the world but
then she
dies and he's depressed floats away in
the stow away like that doesn't sound
like a good idea but you know when you
take something like that uh and you're
willing to change
it uh and you have the group that's
working really well
together then as long as that group is
working well together and say okay
they'll figure something out they'll do
it how do you know when you've got it
you've got an idea you're iterating on
the idea you want it to be Innovative
you want it to be at the highest level
of your creative capacities you're
stress testing it you're failing you're
improving upon it on some level at some
point you have to say this is the script
or this is what the character looks like
or we've all signed on that this is the
way that it's going to be um and I would
assume some of those decisions are more
democratic than others but there has to
be a sense of this is it and that's
another kind of ephemeral mystical thing
like how do you know when you've chosen
the right path decided on the right
project you know approved of this or
approved of that like there's a billion
decisions that go into a movie getting
made or a product ending up on a shelf
and you have to have some conviction as
a leader to say this is what we're
doing and on other occasions to say it's
not quite there yet there there are two
parts to that one of them is just in in
supporting people and and trying to
solve the problem or support them as
they try to solve the
problem is that we support them along
the way but there's one thing that the
creative leader can't do and that is
they can't lose the confidence of their
crew and at that point we will stop it
or we'll pull the plug or we'll replace
them and we have done
that and these are good people they're
put in position because they're talented
we like them but if they lost a
confidence the crew then we have uh we
have to make a big change and uh
Ratatouille was one of those to be
honest where um the we started with an
idea that was an unlikely idea the truth
is the final movie was actually if you
looked at it that it was the fruition of
that original
pitch more than some I just had to go
all the way around the planet to come
back to the same place well no not not
that um in the case of of of of up for
instance it kind of wandered around on
different places and ended up in an
unpredictable place from where it was
but in the case of rou the concept what
it was actually was there all along but
it had a couple of serious difficult
problems and they kept trying to solve
it uh and uh it went through a variety
of things but they couldn't actually
lick the problem and it wasn't
working and so when it wasn't working we
lost the confidence with the crew then
at that point um we brought in Brad Bird
to take it over and Brad resonated with
the idea of the film now the difference
is as a
filmmaker he um he was able to solve the
problem because it was it was
essentially a storytelling problem uh
and figuring out what was getting in the
way so some of the things that were in
there were actually blocking the film so
I'll I'll give an example and that is in
the first version there was this
Chef um gusta
only in that first version Chef gustau
was
alive and then there was uh Remy the rat
who had these aspirations to be a great
chef so part of the problem was whose
story is this is it a Redemption story
for uh for gustau or is it a
aspirational story for Remy back and
forth so and there were complications as
a result of that and so we go we go on
it's like okay we like the idea of this
artistic
aspiration but it isn't working so we
brought in uh Brad Bird he talked with a
friend of his who was a
writer just you know part of his group
of people that he
trusts and came back and said we're
going to kill the
chef the chef is dead so so now all of a
sudden boom things
clicked um and then uh the question was
also how do you actually capture the
essence of what takes place inside of a
kitchen so Brad being a great filmmaker
came in and put in those pieces with
this uh the woman Chef who essentially
was um you know talking about the right
ways of doing it in her abrupt way but
but it was very funny but it very
informative it was short but it told you
a
lot so in the in the end you end up with
something that had the design because
the first director was the one who just
had the who led the design of the
characters the look of the film that was
all the first one in the end the intent
was there of what it was all it's just
that he was able to do it now I'm kind
of telling you you know stories on the
inside about how it is could because it
was hard it was painful it very painful
for the person who couldn't do it and
yeah and I would imagine many moments of
you know kind of nashing of teeth and is
this ever going to work and you know
this is terrible it's not working and
we've made a huge mistake and how are we
going to fix
this I mean that's like all of it right
like I think you know there's this idea
that every you know Pixar movie is this
perfect Jewel box and you know it was
divinely inspired and you know crafted
by Geniuses and ends up on the screen
and it's a long and arduous process but
relatively Conflict Free and failure
free and that's just not the case like
you have said many times every single
Pixar movie was an absolute disaster
before it was good they were bad like
truly bad before they got good and
certainly before they became great and I
think there's a lot of wisdom to extract
from that and how we think about how we
approach challenges and and and projects
in our own life and how we you know
think about that terrible word failure
and and how it inhibits us from you know
doing the grappling and the kind of
having the patience and the diligence
and the hard work to see it through and
get to the other side of it yeah and
that's and there it's still true
today and they haven't gotten any easier
they're not supposed to get easier
they're all supposed to be hard and you
can't there's no matter what
you could take your engineer brain and
your physics mind and try to apply a
template on top of this that's going to
create a hit every time and we're just
going to check these boxes and and move
down this assembly line and create
something that people are going to enjoy
but creativity doesn't work that way no
matter how much you try to impose that
it's not going to work was there a
moment where you thought maybe it would
work yes
so so so here's the funny thing is
because if you look at at what we were
doing because it was you know we BEC be
more expensive and we knew that that uh
part of the problem is we kept redoing
things and we thought well if we could
just get it right or closer at the
beginning it wouldn't cost as much money
the truth was if you brought in any MBA
to examine what we were doing they' come
to the same conclusion quit changing
things so much it it' be a lot cheaper
to make well we knew that it's like a
duh we finally had a film that was
pitched To Us by Andrew Stanton where
the first pitch was
brilliant this was after for Finding
Nemo mhm you know pitch this thing he's
actually probably one of the best people
at pitching I've ever seen it's glorious
it's
entertaining um it's like okay this is
no-brain we're going to do this and I
thought okay since this is so good this
is probably the one where we get it
right up front and it's going to be
easier and cheaper to
make it turned out it was ju had just as
many problems just as much drama cost
just as much so no actually if we
couldn't do it on that one to even think
it as a as the goal is the wrong thing
to do the goal is to make a good move
well you're just creating suff
additional suffering for yourself by
yeah having expectation that that
somehow you screwed up because you still
can't figure out how to avoid all of
these issues that come up with every
single project this they're just going
to happen now I know we all know that
you know if if if cost if films cost too
much to make then we have a problem so
everybody's realistic about it it's like
okay it does cost too much we have to do
things to try to address it but we
shouldn't start off by soling problem
with the illusion that we aren't going
to have
problems so it's how do we keep the cost
down within the reality that we're going
to hit with surprises that are
unexpected well that's what a surprise
is it's unexpected so just you accept
the fact that that's the way it is how
do we do the best that we can within
that and uh and then you're faced with
different challenges you know like with
cost when do things run away
why do they run away what can we do and
we did a lot of things to bring that
back in but we didn't solve it
by by trying to find some
Illusion by just dealing with the the
realities that we had and why people do
things right being in acceptance that
this is just the nature of the Beast
these things come up and your attempt to
solve it might actually you know
sometimes trying to solve the problem
can screw things up what you can't do is
let go of the fact that you have to do
something which is good right if I were
to ask you of all the things that you've
done and everything that you've learned
uh over the course of your career um
what what to your mind made Pixar
special and what can I learn from what
you learned running that company that
could improve my life well I uh I mean
to be honest it's a it is somewhat
difficult to answer that because there
was something about that unique
combination of people that came together
again this happened because Steve and uh
Andrew and Pete and John that that group
that came together but also people that
others wouldn't know about in terms of
the ones who develop the technology like
Bill re and eban Osby and some rather
remarkable people there um so how did
they come together I I do think that
first of all there was some Serendipity
involved um and because I don't believe
I should take credit for having U
thought of things or just like got it on
myself because I
didn't um but I also believe that if you
recognize that Serendipity happens you
can also lose Serendipity because you
don't do something with
it um so I there was that element of it
I think there was something about the
fact that we were all trying to figure
it
out and um that none of us like you know
like neither Steve nor I were also
interested in sort of uh not developing
that as a way of thinking not developing
what in other words here we had a group
that was trying to to figure things out
but it was the group that did it but but
what I'm saying is that Steve didn't
never say he was the one that was doing
that so he wasn't trying to take credit
for it now he was you know the one that
was funding it and he was obviously a
key protector of what we were doing but
he also didn't impose on us what we
did and I wasn't T to impose on other
people what they did and likewise when
we start up each
production we try to think of each one
as trying to do something like that like
they have to f fig it out because there
is something about figuring something
out which makes a group
special I know it's hard to
describe um but whenever I've seen a
group work together to figure things out
then some rather remarkable things
happen and uh so then the question is
how you how do you set it up wherever
you are so that people feel like they
own it they own the culture they have
the U the it's their problem to solve
you're a Avid meditator right mhm yeah
um which is not surprising because I
think you know my view on this or or you
know kind of how I
interpret this
is um an elevation of consciousness like
I see somebody who went into an
organization tried to look at what was
happening objectively tried to think of
a creative solution that would help um
create a better environment for people
to do their best work and you deployed
certain strategies towards that end but
ultimately to me they're all a
reflection of this desire to elevate the
collective Co consciousness of of an
organization like if you can if you can
create an environment where pettiness
and politics and judgment and
backstabbing and all of that Fades into
the background because there's a higher
purpose and a shared sort of sense of
togetherness around that that comes with
a mindful approach to you know being
present with the people that you work
with and and finding a conscious way to
lead them everything else is is is a
product or reflection of that practice
yeah I believe very strongly in that um
I almost made a mistake once too and and
also I I want to add this in is that
after we went public in the year
afterwards um I did ask this question of
myself was was how much of it was
me and uh and at the end of that year I
realized oh actually trying to answer
the question is a bad thing to do
because it's you're thinking about
yourself yeah it's and it's separating
myself from
others and um and so part of meditation
which you know came later was like think
sort of and the weird thing is like
you're to something you're by yourself
but one of the things that comes out of
it is like a genuine connection and the
appreciation of what other people do and
they we're not separate we really aren't
separate and uh to try to you know think
that we are it's it's all by ourselves
like that's a it's actually not good
that's not healthy to think that
did that come to you as a result like
over time as a result of your meditation
practice or was that no I I at the end
of that year light bolt no it was
actually in it was in the year of 1996
in which um I was wrestling with uh two
personal things one of them
was okay you know I had this goal for
many years which is which was one of my
driving forces well
we just did it now
what so by had a loss of purpose after
achieving your goal of creating a
computer animated film that goal being
realized and then suddenly having a a
now what moment yes and and part of it
was well okay just repeating it actually
doesn't feel creative so okay we do a
film again let's just repeating what
we've done this we stopped so no
actually um there's a big problem and
the big problem was
is how does a group do because we so as
a group we did something rather special
but I know that that groups are fragile
so now the question is how do you keep
doing it and it was one of the things
Steve said before we did this he said
the thing that happens to all companies
is right after they get their F their
first product they come out with the
dud so that's like a i he's just making
a comment right I mean other people
people said this a similar sort of thing
but for me it was like an internal
challenge okay how do we not do that so
that that's a a special kind of
challenge right so uh so that was like
the next 10 years like addressing this
thing how does this grrip work and so
for me personally that's the thing to do
but the other one was the realization
that that whatever that is it is
something I Do by myself and that to try
to say okay how much is me is actually a
bad question and the reason I even
brought it up was although it's a little
embarrassing to say that I was saying
something which is you know obviously a
fairly self-oriented thing to
do um but it's I recognize that other
people say the same thing except they
think they need to answer the question
and if they work to answer the question
then that act means they separate
themselves from the group and I did hear
this is from a a director of one of our
short
films and after he made the short film
it was nice short film but then he
left because he said I want to know what
I can do without the safety
net the safety net this group of people
is a safety net no they're not they're
the integral Fabric in which we're
working these are our friends and
they're
like we're all helping each
other um so uh you know it's just how
you think about these things I think
matters yeah and the genuine
appreciation of what others do is
critical where is your head in terms of
the
direction that technology is headed and
how that's going to impact storytelling
in other words you were witness to the
first you know VR headsets 50 years ago
we're seeing rapid developments in in AR
VR AI how is this going to impact how we
tell stories and how people are going to
enjoy stories like it almost feels like
the first computer generated graphics
and animation which you were integral in
has matured to the point where those
tools on some level are going to reach
some kind of tech Singularity with all
these other tools that are out there
where the effects that you see in a
liveaction motion picture and the
computer animation for animated films
there's going to be a blurring of the
lines and these two genres are going to
start overlapping more and more it
affects every industry now but it is
true because we've had this underlying
exponential activity that's been driving
this and um and the interaction between
graphics and the games world so it was
actually the funding that came out of
selling things into the games World
which enabled the in uh the the chips to
be fast enough to enable machine
learning neural networks an idea that
was first written about in
1948 the thing about exponential growth
is it can't continue
forever so what happens is it either
runs out or it um or it morphs into
something else now we're it's pretty
unpredictable except that it can't
continue like it's doing forever so it's
going to have dramatic changes dramatic
changes are more difficult to
predict the important thing is to know
that it is going to change and that it's
unpredictable and that's a hard concept
for people to get just as rapid change
as hard to get so we're definitely one
of those points in in the next while
where something fairly dramatic will
happen just because of all the changes
are going on
um so uh just in terms of Storytelling
the way we communicate with each other
is through stories and if you hold a
child on your lap then you're
communicating some to them if you hand
them a
pad then that's also communicating
something to them and so it's telling a
story but it's not the same kind of
story all these things are at play at
the same time and storytelling is one of
the major components of this but are you
would you say that overall you're a tech
Optimist or are you
fearing what uh some of these powerful
Technologies portend well I'm neither an
optimist nor a pessimist much that I've
always felt like you're a neutralist I'm
a yeah and just like I am with you know
politics or whatever it's like okay
we're not we don't get swayed too far
because we got to this is all very
complicated we have to wind our way
through it and not get derailed because
the problems are hard and since the
problems are hard we think okay how do
we solve it who solves it what are the
consequences and uh so we you get
opinions as you know you get all sorts
of opinions written on all sides of it I
like to know what the opinions are
because they're seeing things that I
can't see I want to know what they see
and it also helps inform Us in terms of
what we do how we behave how we Marshall
the resources that we we
have most people come want to do good in
the world that's a force of of
uh a source of energy so how do how do
you harness the energy of your own
people to do something
good and uh so that's the always the big
question is how do you harness that
energy that desire in a way that they
feel good about it and you feel good
about it and you actually end up with
something that um has a positive impact
that's a pretty good Mission question
isn't it yes and and and for me
personally because it isn't really part
of a mission statement it's like okay
what kind of impact we make what's
what's a positive impact that we can
make in the world I think that's a
beautiful question uh and this thank you
Ed my pleasure I really enjoyed talking
with you it was great to talk to you um
I just you know I adore the book
creativity Inc I think the work that
you're doing is is really vital and
important work and I just have a
tremendous amount of respect for what
you've built and how you comport
yourself in the world and what you
represent so it was an honor to spend
time with you today thank you well it's
been a a true Joy you're uh as a
conversationalist you were wonderful I
appreciate that
thanks come back sometime all right
thank you thank you
thanks that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at Rich roll.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch my
books Finding Ultra voicing change in
the plant power way as well as the plant
power meal planner at meals. Rich
roll.com if you'd like to support the
podcast the easiest and most impactful
thing you can do is to subscribe to the
show on Apple podcasts on Spotify and on
YouTube and leave a review Andor comment
supporting the sponsors who support the
show is also important and appreciated
and sharing the show or your favorite
episode with friends or on social media
is of course awesome and very helpful
and finally for podcast updates special
offers on books the meal planner and
other subjects please subscribe to our
newsletter which you can find on the
footer of any page at Rich roll.com
Today's show was produced and engineered
by Jason Cameo with additional audio
engineering by Kale Curtis the video
edition of the podcast was created by
Blake Curtis with assistance by our
creative director Dan Drake portraits by
Davy Greenberg graphic and social media
assets courtesy of Daniel CIS thank you
Georgia Wy for copywriting and website
management and of course our theme music
was created by Tyler Patt trapper Patt
and Harry mathys appreciate the love
love the support see you back here soon
peace plance
[Music]
namaste